so we have some really great news and
apparently Captain Rex will be in The
Soca TV show so it reads here Tamara
Morrison will be making his return to
the Star Wars Universe later this year
in 2023's Ahsoka Morrison will be
returning as the fan favorite Captain
Rex although it's unclear if he will
appear in flashbacks or in present time
it's also unclear if Morrison will be
playing any other clones in the series
poloni also wrote Order episodes and
according to sources directed at least
two episodes of the series sources also
tell us that lucasfilm Executives have
been absolutely Blown Away by the series
early cuts and that it was a big reason
as to why filoni gots himself a Star
Wars movie drone Favreau produces
alongside filoni as this series is part
of the Mando verse and the subnautis of
the series is this set after the fall of
the Empire Ahsoka follows a former Jedi
Knight Ahsoka Tano as she investigates
an emerging threat to the vulnerable
Galaxy and never was to guess this fret
is no other than Grand Admiral frond we
saw him in an extended trailer which was
shown at Celebration his name was
dropped in the Mando season two and even
Dave floating himself has been
mentioning that they've been building up
to Grand Am reform to be in the next big
fret now man I really hope we see
Captain Rex we have not seen him in live
action before and Tamara Morrison has
not played him before and I know he
would want to do that but I should
mention that apparently we saw caption
Rex in the Battle of and or there's this
guy in the background which kind of
looks like him and I believe they've
flown in mine have even said that this
was him but I do think we'll see Rex in
this series because one take news is
incredibly accurate when it comes to
rumors and leaks like this in the fact
that there are multiple sources reported
on this is a really good sign and
hearing that this series blew the
executives away a lucasfilm is a really
good sign because I feel like we're Drew
for a really good Star Wars show because
we haven't really got one since and or
in my opinion because I wasn't the
biggest fan of the third season of the
Mandalorian but anyway guys let me know
in the comment section below what do you
think of this news and if you haven't
already please subscribe to the channel
and leave a like if you enjoyed thanks
for watching guys